another one from fresh and fit awesome
let's play this one she wants to bring a
friend we'll call it
every time I invite a girl she wants to
bring a friend translation I don't find
you that attractive to the point that I
want to spend time with you one-on-one
in a setting where intimacy may be
possible so let me bring a friend as a
backup option so I can quickly and
conveniently excuse myself from the
situation if it's no longer interesting
to me don't be stupid guys no free
attention move on to the next girl it's
true okay so with the one exception
on a first visit like a first date girls
will sometimes say bring a friend for
safety if they're meeting up with you
for the first time especially in this
crazy world we're in now oftentimes
they'll say they'll bring a friend
because they want to make sure you're
not weird you're not like some type of
murderer you're not some type of rapist
your friends aren't super weird
your house isn't weird like you have a
house party you you don't maybe you take
them to a club and you're like oh my God
this guy's into like some sort of Kink
and you're not you know something weird
sometimes happens on that first meeting
so I'm gonna give it a pass for that
first one but guys if she's taking her
girlfriend with her every time all that
means is that she is praying like she's
setting up all the filters so you don't
make a move like oh he's not gonna kiss
me if she's there oh he's not gonna make
a move oh he's not gonna all that and
they may still go because maybe they
want you to buy the drinks
maybe they want you to like buy the
dinner
maybe they want like you know an excuse
to get out and you take her out she's
got her friend but she's got her eye on
the room so maybe she meets somebody
else that night don't think that it's
girls will do that
um and people's got nothing better to do
that night so nobody else asked her out
she's like all right I'll go but I don't
really like him so I'm bring my squad
girls love one-on-one time with a man
love one-on-one time with a man if they
really like him they crave it they dig
it they want that intimacy of some kind
they're attracted they want that close
conversation all that stuff
um he's on the money with that one
except for the first one remember first
date
could be a little scary just saying but
let's not get this Twisted you know that
most men are far too naive to accept
this advice they're saying oh she's
bringing a friend you know what's going
through his head I hate that you can go
hot there
you think they're gonna be thinking it's
a threesome that's exactly what that
happened he's naive and hopeful and
that's exactly what he's thinking I
would think oh would they be thinking
like oh maybe it'll be a girl for my
friend like that'll be like a double
date no you went straight to the man
okay if it's one guy and she's like hey
can I bring a friend yeah he's gone well
[ __ ] you can bring as many friends as
you want you think that's a very
confident man to think that well guys
are stupid if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here
foreign
[Music]